hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this one i'm going to
quickly show you how to update your zoom
hd hardware actually firmware settings
to the newest version 4.3 which was
available just a few minutes ago today
as i'm filming this so in order to do
this when your device is connected to
your computer go up to the top to
settings
go over to the left to device
and go to player update and to view the
setting connect your zoom so i'm going
to connect my zoom hd
so once you've connected your zune hd
you will either get a message saying
your player is up to date with version
4.1 or that it needs an update to
version 4.3 if it does say you're up to
date with version 4.1 in the united
states this is actually a common problem
with the zun hd 16 gig and here's a way
around that
go to start go to control panel
and open up your settings and time for
region
and once you've opened this up you can
go to change the country or region and
change your country from the united
states to canada
once you've changed it hit apply and
then hit ok and then when you go back
into the zoom software it will detect
that you have an update ready to version
4.3
once you've done this and updated your
player you'll notice a bunch of uh
different software updates which i'll go
over in the next video
so make sure you're subscribed for that
and once you've done that you want to go
back to your control panel and update
and make sure you go back to the united
states for your region
so that is how to briefly uh update the
version of your zune hd firmware
firmware to version 4.3 and i hope you
enjoyed this tutorial and i'll talk to
you guys in the next video thank you for
watching peace
you